[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHERYL SUCHORS:
Once upon a time,
in 1998, I vowed to
climb 48 mountains.
And what I'd like to do for
the next 40 minutes or so
is share a little of
my journey with you.
I'll make some remarks,
read three short passages
from my book, offer some
thoughts about mental training,
and leave us with time for
question and discussion.
You game?
All right.
Now, if you had known
me back in 1998,
you might have thought
this vow was questionable.
I had a bum knee.
I have scoliosis
that is severe enough
that one doctor, when
I was in my teens,
said don't ever pick up
anything heavier than a tissue.
I was no longer in
my 20s or my 30s.
I was 48.
And my record with
sports was not promising.
I had tried and
loved three of them,
and had to give each of them
up when my body failed me,
twice ending with surgery.
And lastly, though
I hate to admit it,
I'm afraid of heights.
Nonetheless, this is
what I decided to climb,
Mount Tripyramid in the White
Mountains of New Hampshire.
All three peaks of it.
It was going to be a
serious challenge for me.
It was two and a
half times as long
as I'd ever hiked back in the
day, on much easier trails.
It was one of the taller
ones in the Whites.
It was cold that
day in early October
when we decided to go for it.
And it was going to take
pretty much all day.
Book time doesn't
even include things
like lunch or bio breaks or
picture-taking or view-enjoying
or pretty much anything.
Along with me on this
venture I invited Kate,
to my next-door neighbor
and my best friend.
We did pretty much
everything together.
She was my daughter's
Auntie Kate.
She was my dog's Auntie Kate.
I also invited Sarah, my
best friend from college.
Now, Sarah and I
were the same age,
but Kate was six years older.
So she was 54 when we started.
And it's kind of fitting
that I introduce you
early on to a couple of friends,
because among the themes
in my book, friendship
is certainly one.
Now, one thing that
I did not appreciate
before I went on the
Mount Tripyramid hike
was its elevation gain.
I was kind of like, meh.
Now I've come to
think of it like this.
Picture for yourselves a
two-story house with an attic.
All right?
Put another one just
like it next door.
Pick up the second one, put
it on top of the first one,
and keep going.
You need to add up
100 houses to reach
3,000 feet of elevation gain.
And we'd be doing
that on rocky, rooty,
ankle-busting,
knee-turning trails.
And I'm here to tell
you, it was hard.
We were on the Scaur Ridge
Trail, the three of us,
climbing up on our hands
and knees over boulders.
I did not expect that at all.
And I was starting to
get really worried.
I was getting anxious
that I wouldn't
be able to make it
to the top and I
wouldn't be able to
finish this event that
was so important to me.
I'd like to read you
a couple of paragraphs
so that you get a glimpse of
why finishing was so important.
After months of
preparing for this hike,
I still didn't know if I was
strong enough, tough enough,
brave enough.
As it had during the night,
worry eroded my confidence.
Would I finish?
Other possible problems--
storms, rutting moose, bears--
I didn't have the experience
to be troubled by.
It was me that worried me.
We continued leveraging
and hoisting,
maintaining the
lineup that would
continue for much of the day--
Sarah in the lead,
me in the middle,
and Kate slowly, and with
no apparent angst about it,
bringing up the rear.
Kate's face was
sweaty but determined.
I thought, she really
is stronger than I am.
Not as fast, but stronger.
At some core level, she
seemed unfazed by this trail.
Sarah was fast, and Kate
was sure, but what was I?
I no longer defined
myself as a partner
in a national organization or
president of my own consulting
firm, and I could hardly
call myself a writer.
I needed to be a
hiker, a good one.
But I relied on a blend
of fear and willpower,
with neither Sarah's agility
nor Kate's character.
So now you understand
that I was in the middle
of a late mid-career change
from the world of business
to following my bliss,
something I'd always
wanted to do since
childhood, to write a novel.
And it was not going well.
So there I am on the
trail, anxious, worried,
concerned I was never
going to finish,
when something happened.
Kate, who was
behind me, called up
and motioned me to come over
to see something, which I did.
And when I went back down,
this is what I found.
Kate unzipped the small
pouch belted at her navel
and pulled out a camera.
Moving to her side, I
leaned down to where
she crouched on the trail.
She pointed out a whole row of
icicles hanging from a boulder
to our right.
They glistened, wetly
silver against a backdrop
of emerald moss.
Wow, I whispered, as Kate
moved in for a close-up.
I pulled off a glove
and reached out
to slide my finger down one of
the six-inch sparkling daggers,
cold, slick, solid.
I yearned to break
one off and lick it,
but they were too
beautiful to ruin.
I remembered my mother
coming into my childhood
room in the early-morning dark
to murmur, it's a snow day.
The exhilaration,
the sense of freedom,
a day in the white glare of
snow making lopsided snowballs
and forts, plucking icicles
from tree branches until I grew
chilled.
Then the warmth
inside the house that
fogged my glasses, my mother
pressing her warm cheek
to my cold one, saying this was
her favorite moment of winter,
offering her a bit of icicle
that still clung to my mitten.
The taste, gritty,
with bits of bark
and the strange
bloody tang of dirt.
Perhaps Kate was
remembering, too.
Aren't they amazing?
I looked at her, and
she looked at me,
and it settled into my
brain that we were here
on the spine of one
enormous mountain,
just as we'd planned,
just as we'd trained for.
And it was cold and
cloudy, but we were warm,
and we were climbing,
and we'd probably hiked
five miles already, as long
as I'd ever hiked in my life.
We grinned big wolf
grins at each other.
So the hike didn't
get any easier,
but I'd had a glimpse of the
wonder of the natural world.
And I have to say, it gave me
a whole lot more enthusiasm
for this hike.
Then things got tougher.
You see on the left
here-- yes, left--
Sarah on the Scaur Ridge Trail.
So I did mean boulders
that we had to hike up.
And then the other photograph
takes place seven miles later
and three peaks later, at the
start of the South Slide, which
basically drops off the
edge of the photograph,
off the edge of the mountain
like a plumb line for about
1,000 feet, a plumb
line filled with scree.
How was I coping with
my fear of heights?
You'll just have to read
the book to find out.
Well, we did finish.
Only took us 10 hours.
And it took a week for my
leg muscles to unclench.
But it didn't matter at
all because I was elated.
I couldn't believe that
I'd actually done it.
Sarah disappeared back
into her busy life,
but Kate felt the rapture.
And on our early-morning
training walks,
we felt so proud of
ourselves, so strong,
we strutted through
the neighborhood,
wanting to pick up
cars and save babies.
Now, something else
happened on that mountain.
We met a guy who told us
about the 4,000 Footers,
and that we were
standing on one.
He said we, too, could join
the 4,000 Footer Club after--
only after-- we had
hiked all 48 of them.
And when we did,
what did we get?
You're looking at it.
We got this patch.
Well, I thought this was a
ridiculous, possibly demented
idea.
Who would do such a crazy thing?
But it stuck with me.
And over the course of
the next days and weeks,
I thought, well, I bet the
folks who join that 4,000 Footer
Club are goal-oriented people.
Well shoot, I'm a
goal-oriented person.
I can do this thing.
The next year, I went out
and bagged three more peaks,
two with Kate and one a
surprise venture on my own,
with nobody but my
little Bichon Frise,
Juniper, who, despite
her appearance,
was an awesome hiking dog.
So Kate and I felt pretty
pleased with ourselves,
until one evening I was in
the kitchen preparing dinner,
and my daughter
Casey, who was nine,
was doing homework
at the kitchen table.
And she said, Mom,
I did the math.
It's going to take you 21 and
a half years to finish the 48,
and you'll be 70 and
a half years old,
and Auntie Kate will
be 76 and a half.
Kate and I had
not done the math.
This was clearly not right.
We couldn't allow
it to be like this.
So we took the intensive
eight-week-long winter hiking
course that the AMC puts
on so that we could now
hike all year long.
We were ready to rock
and root, my friends.
Fate, however, had other ideas.
In the very early days of the
optimistic new millennium,
Kate underwent surgery, and
they found ovarian cancer.
Three months later, I was
diagnosed with invasive breast
cancer.
We both went into treatment.
Like Kate, I had surgeries,
rounds of chemotherapy,
and then I began a five-year
course of tamoxifen.
And everything gave me
lasting side effects.
I still have side effects
today, as a matter of fact.
And then, as you learn in
the prologue of my book,
in the spring of 2002, ovarian
cancer killed my best friend.
I was bereft.
I had no idea how
to fill the void
this woman left in my life.
I wasn't much up for
continuing my quest.
But before she
died, Kate made me
promise that I would continue.
She said, it will keep you
strong the way you've kept me.
She also persuaded
me that I needed
to get another hiking buddy.
And I didn't want to, but I did,
because I had more reasons now
to hike than ever before.
The mountains were
a place where I
could go to heal from the
trauma of my own breast cancer.
And in the wild, it
was spacious enough
to absorb some of the grief
I felt over losing Kate.
I had made her another
promise, that I
would take some of her ashes
to the top of a 4,000 footer.
I chose Mount Monroe because
was in the Presidentials,
which are the highest
of the 4,000 Footers,
and the grandest and
the most difficult.
I wasn't strong enough yet
to do Mount Washington, which
you see in the background
of this picture,
with its towers and observatory.
And Mount Monroe, next
door to it, this fellow
is standing on the
trail leading up
to the summit of Mount Monroe,
so the summit kind of protrudes
out towards us
from this picture.
But it was plenty high enough to
push me to and past my limits.
Sarah came with me.
I was not strong enough
emotionally or physically to go
on my own.
And together, we set Kate
free in the raw, wild winds
above Oakes Gulf.
To continue my quest, I
next chose Mount Moosilauke.
And I picked it because it
was one of the easier ones.
At least, it was easier
than what I had been doing.
It was seven and a half
miles long round-trip,
with 2,450 feet of elevation
gain, or think 81 houses.
Substantial, but still easier.
It was a pivotal
climb for me because I
went with someone new, Ginny.
Ginny and I had known
each other from our kids'
school for years,
and we were friends,
and now we were even
training buddies,
but we had never hiked together.
She'd never been to the Whites.
She'd certainly never
been to a 4,000 footer.
And Kate had just died.
I thought you might enjoy
this image of Mount Moosilauke
from 1912.
As you can see, on the
summit is a little thing
that was known as the Tip
Top House, a small hotel.
And that carriage road was
for horse-drawn buggies
to take visitors and
guests up to the summit.
That's the exact same
trail that Ginny and I
used to ascend to the summit.
And while it's nowhere near as
broad and pristine as that now,
it's delightful footing.
Lots of pine needles
and nice, soft dirt.
It was wonderful.
Great way to get up there.
And we got along so well.
She also loved wildflowers,
and learning about them.
And even though I
tried so hard not to,
she expected me to
compare her to Kate.
She even asked me questions
about Kate and our hiking
experiences, and she
held me when I cried.
Better yet, she wanted to do
another 4,000 footer with me,
even though our
trail coming down
was quite direct from the top,
where the Tip Top House is,
pretty much straight down.
And it was quite stony,
and difficult on the knees
and feet.
And it really kicked my
energy a bunch, I have to say.
Let's take just a quick trip
through some 4,000 Footers
so you get to see
some other ones.
Many of them start in
the woods, like this one.
That's me back in the day.
And this trail,
Falling Waters, goes up
to the somewhat famous
Franconian Ridge Trail
and to Mounts Lincoln
and Lafayette.
And it has a lovely, gradual
ascent for the first mile,
and then it gets wicked,
diabolically steep and hard.
Hence, its nickname,
Falling Bodies Trail.
The Presidentials are the
grandest, as I've said.
And this is a geological
feature that I love.
It's called the Great Gulf.
And I could just
stare at it forever.
On the way up to Mount Moriah--
that's me again, trying out
yet another knee brace--
there were some
interesting moments.
Fear of heights?
Oh, yes, my goodness.
Here's a friend, Clara,
a wonderful person
whom I got to know strictly
through hiking, out
on the summit of Mount Flume.
And lest you think that
all of the 4,000 Footers
are just piles of
rock or rubble,
here's some that
are lushly green.
And what I love about
Bond & Bondcliff--
and there's another
one called West Bond--
is that, when you're there,
you cannot see a single sign
of human civilization.
It's wonderful.
Just this wilderness to
absorb and appreciate.
The Wildcats are a
series of five peaks
that live across the road
from Mount Washington.
And here, you see first
Sarah, followed by Ginny,
followed by Rosemary, another
friend who hiked with me.
Now, as in any endurance sport,
the mental game is paramount.
Right?
Even when our bodies
can be totally fit
and trained and ready,
our minds can do us in.
And this is true on
any marathon endeavor--
sports, but other
things like a renovation
project for your house,
or a months-long campaign
to get a promotion, or a
multi-year design project.
Whatever it is, we have to both
stay trained on what sometimes
feels like in the far distance,
the goal we want to attain,
but also we have to
keep moving forward
and keep ourselves on track.
One of the ways that I
found that helped me do this
was finding role models.
Now, on the trails,
I mostly saw men,
so I was keen to find a woman
role model to teach and inspire
me.
And the woman that
I came up with
was a climber called
Annie Smith Peck.
Has anybody heard of
her, Annie Smith Peck?
She was amazing.
Here's an image of
Annie Smith Peck
on the cover of a book that
was a biography written
about her in 2017.
And that's what she wore to
summit the Matterhorn in 1895.
And she scandalized
the world not
because she summited
as a woman, that
had already been done in 1871,
but because she wore pants.
She was a wonderful
role model for me
because she didn't even start
hiking until her mid 30s, which
was considered pretty old.
She hiked, she practiced for 10
years before going on to summit
the Matterhorn at age 45.
And then she became the
first person, woman or man,
to climb the highest peak in
the Americas, Mount Huascaran
in Peru, about 22,000 feet high.
I tell you, every time I read
anything about Annie Smith
Peck, I just wanted
to run right out
and tackle another 4,000 Footer.
And isn't that what we want
our role models to do for us?
To inspire us, to encourage
us, to keep us going.
I also found it important
to write down the progress
that I was making, because this
was a multi-year effort for me.
And so each day,
I write down what
I do for physical
training, mental training,
and what I do professionally.
So nowadays, working on my book.
I find that, when I go to
review it at the end of a week,
I'm always astounded how
much I've forgotten that I
did earlier on in the week.
And it's very helpful to be
able to look back and see
that, yes, I have
achieved things,
yes, I'm making progress.
I am moving forward toward
that long-term goal.
Another way that I did that
was with this birthday gift
from my husband, Larry, who
mounted it on a poster board
and hung it on my wall.
He strategically placed
48 blue pins on it.
And so every time I
came back from a climb,
I would swap out the
blue pin for a red one
with a number on it
that corresponded
to the number of 4,000
Footer it was for me.
I could see at a glance all
that I had accomplished,
and I could also see at a glance
exactly what I had left to go.
And it was very helpful in
terms of choosing my next hike.
Another mental training tip--
celebrate.
Here you see Clara and I doing
what became a tradition on all
my hikes, the peak dance.
It was designed to make us
look as ridiculous, as goofy as
humanly possible.
We sang this absurd little
ditty that I made up.
And why did we do it?
Well, every time we
did it, we laughed.
And as studies have shown,
laughter is good medicine.
But in addition,
when you celebrate,
your body releases dopamine,
one of the happy chemicals
in the body, like serotonin.
Dopamine is awesome
because not only does it
help you set your goals
in the first place,
but when you achieve
them, it gives you
this big rush of pleasure.
So why not celebrate
as often as you can?
Now I'd like to
talk about something
that is incredibly important to
me, and became so in my book.
Finding a home for
myself in nature
became a chief part
of every climb.
When I hiked, I made sure,
no matter with whom I was,
that I had time to
hike alone so that I
could tune into the
natural world around me
and make that connection to
nature that we were made to do.
It was such a gift.
No matter how hard the
climb had been-- and for me,
they were pretty much all hard--
no matter how injured or
bruised I was when I got back,
I always felt that I had come
back brimming with energy.
It was as if there was this
internal reservoir that
had gone dry, and I filled
it up on the mountains
with exhilarance and
exuberance and just a zest for.
Living
As Rachel Carson once wrote--
you remember Rachel
Carson, the author in 1962
of "The Silent
Spring," she was one
of our early conservationists
and environmentalists--
she said, those who contemplate
the beauty of the Earth
develop reserves
of strength that
endure as long as life lasts.
I'd like to read you a passage
from my book that gives you
a glimpse of how I felt on
the top of my sixth 4,000
Footer, the one you
see here, the larger
one on the left, Mount Osceola.
On the right is East
Peak, also a 4,000 Footer.
When I hiked Mount Osceola,
it was my first 4,000 Footer
after cancer.
It had been a year since
the end of treatment,
two years since my last climb.
And I was still quite weak, but
it was a glorious fall day up
in Waterville Valley,
New Hampshire,
where we had an apartment.
And I persuaded my
family to go with me.
The temperature was gorgeous.
The sun was shining.
And it was just a day to try it.
It was 6.4 miles round-trip,
a little over 2,000 feet,
so think 70 houses.
I thought, yeah, I bet
I can do 70 houses.
So as soon as we started
off, Casey, now 11 years old,
and Juniper just tore off.
And once they were out of sight,
I begged Larry to slow down.
He was already
carrying all my gear.
I couldn't even manage
my water bottle.
And then, after
the first mile, I
was stumbling and
shambling along.
Larry was boosting
me up over rocks.
And sometimes, he went ahead
and leaned down and pulled me up
a ledge.
As we got closer to the
top, I was literally
grabbing a leg with both
hands to pull it forward.
But I was so grateful to be
back in the mountains again.
Not just because of my quest
and the 4,000 Footer club,
but because I was
back in the wild,
where I felt I
belonged, where I felt
like I was one with everything.
Casey and Juniper
summited first,
then Larry hauled
me over the top.
I stood there
breathing and shaking.
After I waved them
on, they wandered off
to explore the broad ledges
and take in the view.
Once my legs steadied, I crossed
the summit to the nearest edge,
expecting to see a pretty view
of skinny Waterville Valley,
just from a different
orientation.
I was wrong, delightfully wrong.
Gazing eastward, I marveled
at Mount Tripyramid,
the brute size of it.
Words rolled through
my weary brain--
majestic, powerful, humbling.
I turned slowly to
soak up the landscape,
allowing myself to believe that,
though sometimes nearly carried
by Larry, I had actually
summited Osceola post-cancer.
I turned to the
northeastern view.
Before me spread wave
after wave of mountain.
I counted no fewer
than seven ranges,
each surging behind another.
They stretched to the
horizon emerald blue,
and as they marched
farther away,
shadowy, cerulean shapes that
touched the deeper blue of sky.
I felt caught up in the
motion of those rocky waves.
I could take off into
those mountains up and down
and over until I knew
each and every peak.
I could let go of my
complicated city life
and live in the mountains,
exploring them all day long
and sleeping in them at night.
The vast, astonishing
beauty caused,
along with the joy, an ache.
The mountains
called for grandeur,
and I was only one person,
and at that, a lesser version
of who I was before.
If only I were a more
tolerant, better person.
I longed for everyone to
experience this breaking open
of the spirit that was at
once nourishing, illuminating,
and sweetly painful.
Here, a world existed in which
all things, small and large,
mobile and rooted, oxygen-giving
and oxygen-absorbing
had a place in a
balanced, sacred whole.
I was on such a mountain high
I didn't even know I was high.
I felt certain that, if
everyone could spend time
in the mountains,
it would change
the fabric of our society.
I was ready to hug all
the strangers on Osceola,
invoke their promise to
safeguard this place,
and take the lessons garnered
here back home to share.
We could organize.
"Mom!"
The sound of Casey's
voice startled me.
Deep in my mountain reverie,
I'd forgotten she existed.
I hiked 43 of the 48
mountains in my 50s
after cancer, finishing up
in 2008 at the age of 58.
Doing the 4,000 Footers
inspired me to write a book.
And though it's
not a novel, I do
feel that it helped me
accomplish my dream of having
a published book.
I finished my quest a different
and, I hope, a better person.
Certainly a more humble
and grateful one,
one who better understood
how little control
she had over life,
and who understood
she needed to redefine success
so that it met my needs
and fulfilled me.
And also one who took every
opportunity to put herself
in the embrace of nature.
Now, I'm still getting
out and hiking.
And in a few weeks,
I'll turn 68.
I'm taking my hiking experience
to other parts of the world.
For my 61st birthday, Larry
and I went to New Zealand.
You see him there on the
Kepler Track, one of the great
walks in New Zealand.
We did this in late spring,
and we were totally shocked,
as was everyone else
around us, to be faced
with the danger of avalanches.
Back in the US,
Jenny and I signed up
for a Sierra Club trip
in the Northern Cascades
of Washington.
The trip was called
Wildflowers and Wanderlust,
and it was gorgeous.
Here, you see Hikes Pass,
up around 10,000 feet.
In the summer of 2017, Larry
and I enjoyed a trip to Poland.
And here we are
hiking the highest
of the Carpathian mountain
range, the High Tatras.
I leave you and end my
story with three wishes.
May you continue to do your
utmost to preserve and protect
our planet and its
health, our only home,
before it's too late.
May you continue spending
time outdoors, maybe even more
than you already do, whether
that's noticing nature
in the form of trees
on the sidewalk
or some little weed
that's grown up
through cracks in the pavement.
I mean, what a lesson in
endurance and perseverance
that is.
Or better yet, if you can
get out into the wild.
I mean, we were made
to connect with nature.
And I hope you've
come to understand
some of the benefits I derived
by spending as much time as I
did and do out in nature.
And lastly, may you succeed on
your own quests, whatever kind
of mountains those involve.
I believe what Eleanor
Roosevelt said,
the future belongs
to those who believe
in the beauty of their dreams.
So keep dreaming.
Thanks for listening.
[CLAPPING]